توقفوا عن خلق الاعداء وضمونا فورا الى
حلفكم هكذا صرخ بها الاوكران في وجه
النيتو المانيا وبريطانيا تدخلان في معارك
جويه خطيره ضد روسيا وبوتين يدخل سلاحا
سريا الى الحرب الاوكرانيه قد يغير سير
المعارك والرئيس الصيني يعيد الامل للرئيس
الاوكراني فهل يتمسك بالحكمه الصينيه
ويترك يد الغرب وتقرير امريكي روسيا
ستسيطر تماما على اجواء اوكرانيا والجبهات
الاوكرانيه في مهب الريح بكين ترد على
التحضيرات الامريكيه من الاراضي الفلبينيه
ولندن تحذر من كارثه عالميه والسبب تايوان
الهدنه السودانيه لا تجدي نفعا ومجلس
الامن الدولي يعقد قمه طارئه للتدخل
واشنطن تعزز جاهزيه الردع النوويه بوجه
كوريا الشماليه وتركيا
نحن نحاربكم على الدوام بوتين يظهر اسلحته
السريه
الحرب الاوكرانيه تدخل نفقا مظلما لتعلن
موسكو ان رصيدها في الصبر اوشك على النفاذ
ولكن قوانين الحروب تتكيف مع القوانين
الفيزيائيه فلكل فعل رده فعل لقد كنت اجيد
القفز من على السور المدرسه ولكني لا اعلم
كيف تسلل هذا القانون الى راسي هنا وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه تعلن ان قوتها اسقطت قاذفه
سوق 25 اوكرانيه فوق خرزون وتمكنت من تحيد
ثماني مجموعات تخريب واستطلاع للعدو وانها
قتلت اكثر من 260 جنديا اوكرانيا على جميع
المحاور الضربه تتوالى على اوكرانيا حتى
انها يمكن ان تبقى الى نهايه الربيع وبدون
وسائل الدفاع جوي وذلك بس استنزاف
الاحتياطي من صواريخ ارض جو السوفيتيه
والغربيه وليست هناك امكانيه لتعويضها
ولذلك فان روسيا ستحقق السيطره الكامله
باجواء اوكرانيا ما سيؤثر سلبا على
الاوضاع في كل الجبهات بحسب
الامريكيه اي حينها قد تنتهي المقاومه
الاوكرانيه او توشك على السقوط النهائي
اذا ما انقطع شريان الدعم الغربي وليس ذلك
فحسبه بل ان بوتين ادخل سلاحا سريا في
الحرب الاوكرانيه نعم وللمره الاولى تظهر
دبابات تي اربعه عشر انماطا من الجيل
الجديد في المعارك وهي دبابات روبوتيه
خفيه قادره على تحويل مدينه الى انقاض في
دقائق معدوده وفق صحيفه البريطانيه فيا
لها من ضربه قويه
هل من مغيث لياتي الغيث الغربي واوله حيث
اعلن مصدر في هيئه الامن الروسيه ان بلدان
النيتو سلمت عبر رومانيا 30 دبابه الى
منطقه اوديسات لتجديد كتيبه دبابات القوات
الاوكرانيه بحسب نوفوستي لكن هل هذه
الدبابات كافيه للمقاومه ام ان لقوات
موسكو رايا اخر ليصرخ وزير الخارجيه
الاوكراني ديميتروكوليبا في وجهت قائلا
كفاكم اعذارا وابداوا بعمليه ضم اوكرانيا
للنيتو فكل شيء ممكن عندما تتوفر الاراده
السياسيه وذلك بحسب شبكه
لتاتي جرعه الامل من الرئيس الصيني في
خطوه طال انتظارها من طرف الرئيس
الاوكراني
حيث اجرى شيء
[موسيقى]
لاول مره منذ بدء الحرب في اوكرانيا هناك
قال شيء تفوضى وسبيل الوحيد للخروج من
النزاع لتعلن الحكومه الصينيه في وقت لاحق
انها سترسل وفدا الى اوكرانيا بهدف البحث
عن تسويه سياسيه للنزاع فهل ياتي الحل على
ايدي اصحاب العيون الضيقه لتجيب الناطقه
باسم الخارجيه الروسيه
بقولها ان موسكو تلاحظ استعداد الجانب
الصيني لبذل الجهود لتاسيس عمليه التفاوض
لكنها تعتقد ان المشكله ليست في نقص الخطط
الجيده حتى الان لان نظام كيا يرفض ايه
مبادرات معقوله لتسويه الازمه ويفرض مطالب
غير واقعيه بحسب تعبيرها وها هو بوتين
يعود ليواصل رده على الغرب حيث اصدر
مرسوما يضع اصول واموال ما وصفها بالدول
غير الصديقه في روسيا تحت تصرف الهيئه
الفيدراليه لاملاك الدوله واكد المرسوم ان
هذه الخطوه تاتي ردا على مصادره الولايات
المتحده ودول اخرى او تجميدها اصولا روسيه
لشركات مملو لمواطنين رؤوس ومن الحروب على
الارض الى معارك السماء حيث شهدت سماء بحر
البلطيق مواجهه بين الطائرات روسيه واخرى
المانيه وبريطانيه في تحدي جديد بين قوات
تلك البلاد المتنافسه خصوصا بالملف
الاوكراني حيث تعتبر المانيا وبريطانيا من
ابرز اعضاء حلف شمال الاطلسي النيتو
الداعم للقوات الاوكرانيه وتعتبر المنطقه
ساحه تنافس خطيره بين روسيا ودول حلف
الناتو حيث برزت خطورتها مع المواجهات
الروسيه الاوروبيه خصوصا في اوكرانيا
وتضارب المصالح فيها فهل تنذر هذه
المواجهات بحرب طاحنه
نعم بالفعل ما جاء عن الجيش الالماني ان
طائرات مشتركه
للجيش الالماني وكذلك لبريطانيا قامت
باعتراض ثلاث طائرات طائرتان حربيه وطائره
شحن يوشن كانت تحلق فوق بحر البلطيق بحر
الشمال واشنطن تلعب بالنار
الاجواء متوتره ومشحونه بما فيه الكفايه
والولايات المتحده تواصل صب الزيت على
النار هنا انطلقت اكبر مناورات عسكريه
مشتركه بين امريكا والفلبين في بحر جنوب
الصين الذي تطالب بكين بالسياده عليه
وبمشاركه نحو 18 الف جندي بكين لم تقف
صامته وهو وزير الخارجيه الصيني تشينغ يصل
الى العاصمه الفلبينيه مانيلا في محاوله
لتعزيز علاقات بلده مع الفلبين لكن اصحاب
العيون الضيقه يحضرون لشيء ما في الفلبين
فهل يطردون القواعد الامريكيه من هناك ومن
جزر الفلبين الى الجزيره التايوانيه والتي
قد تسبب ازمه عالميه حيث قال وزير
الخارجيه البريطاني
لو اندلعت حرب عبر المضيق فلن تكون ماساه
انسانيه فحسب بل ستدمر
تريليون دولار في التجاره العالميه لن
تنجو اي دوله من التداعيات مشيرا الى ان
موقعها البعيد لا يؤمن اي حمايه مما سيشكل
ضربه كارثيه للاقتصاد العالمي والصين
مؤكدا انه من الضروري الا يتخذ اي طرف اي
اجراء لتغيير الوضع القائم
السودان الجريح السودان يواصل في مرحله
الخطر ومع ان اوضاع السودانيين الانسانيه
لم تكن في افضل احوالها قبل اندلاع
الصراعات ولم يكن ينقصها الا صراع جديد كي
تتدهور الى هذا المستوى وها هي تتدهور يا
ساده هنا اعلنت وزاره الداخليه السودانيه
ان قوات الدعم السريع اقتحمت خمسه سجون
واطلقت سراح من الحادي والعشرين حتى
الرابع والعشرين من ابريل ومن بينها سجن
كوبر مما تسبب في عدد ممنسوبي اداره
السجون واطلقت سراحات جميع النزلاء وفق
البيان بينما تجددت المعارك بشتى انواع
الاسلحه بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع مع سماع دوي انفجارات متقطعه وسط
وغرب مركز الخرطوم تاتي هذه التطورات بعد
ساعات من خروج عدد من قاده النظام
السوداني المعزول من السجن وتبادل الطرفي
الصراعي المسؤوليه عن الحادثه كلها هذه
الاحداث في ظل هدنات معلنه فماذا لو
استمرت المعارك دون اي هدمه لينظر العالم
الى السودان بعين الرحمه اذ عقد مجلس
الامن جلسه لبحث تطورات صراع السوداني
هناك طلبا الاتحاد الافريقي بايجاد اليه
لايجاد حوار بين الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريع الجميع يطالب بضبط النفس
والعوده للحوار بينما تحاول واشنطن
التنسيق مع شركاء الاقليميين
واصحاب المصلحه من المدنيين السودانيين
لانشاء لجنه للاشراف على مفاوضات وقف
العنف والاعمال الغدائيه بالسودان فهل
تنجح الوساطات
الاحداث والتطورات كشف مسؤول امريكي كبير
ان بلاده سترسل غواصه نوويه للتوقف في
كوريا الجنوبيه بهدف تعزيز قدرات الرضع في
مواجهه كوريا الشماليه في تحول امريكي
خطير لمواجهه خطر صواريخ
لقي عضو مجلس خبراء القياده في ايران ايات
العباس علي سليمان مصرعه بهجوم مسلح في
مدينه بابل صرف شمال البلاد بحسب وكاله
مهر للانباء صرح وزير الداخليه التركي
سليمان صويلو بان تركيا تحارب الولايات
المتحده من خلال محاربه الارهاب مجددا
اتهامه لواشنطن بالسعي لاقامه دوله ارها
على حدود بلاده بوتين يظهر بعضا من اسلحته
السريه والصين تستخدم حلفاء واشنطن للرد
على الاداره الامريكيه والسودان في لحظه
من الضياع
[موسيقى]